Hello everybody my name is Markiplier
and welcome back to Five Nights at Freddy's: Help Wanted.
We've got just
One
two three four five more challenges to go.
We're not over yet, we've got the Dark Rooms.
Which SHOULDN'T be too bad, to be perfectly honest.
So if these go smooth,
I'm hoping that I won't be too stressed about this.
I just don't know how the timing's gonna be, in the dorkness.
But I'm gonna TRY it real good.
IN THE DORKNESS. DORKNESS.
Okay, woah. Wait wait. WAIT a minute.
Wait WAIT a minute.
WHY am I tiny?
WHY AM I TEENSY TINY???
Wait. IN WHOSE WORLD?!?
What the...
Okay alright woah.
WHA
Okay.
Alright. I'm tiny
But that's all right, because I may be accurate to my own height right now,
But YOU, are not gonna beat me.
Uh-huh not with your, not with your
Big ol teeth and your tangly dick.
Yeeah not this time.
Alright. Come on.
I maybe small, but I'm mighty.
I got big ol' fists. Yeah.
You wouldn't want none of this, would ya?
Would ya?
Haya!
Okay. Alright. So I think it's the same type of game it's just that for some reason I'm tiny.
Alright I gotta wait a lot longer because otherwise I'm gonna die.
HUH...
WOOoah kay.
DU!
Ho Ho
HUEH.
Aha, okay.
Ahh man I gotta move him.
Too early ahh god damn it.
Ooh I'm gonna die.
Shit!
Ookay AHH FUCK!
Alright here we go here we go.
Here we go here we go.
HOO!
HEEY!!! YEEAH!!!
EAT... DON'T EAT!
Actually eat NOTHING of me. Eat absolutely little of me.
Okay.
Yee!
Alright. Okay.
Heh heh heh heh WOAH fucking what the fuck?
What the hell are you?!
What are you?!
"I'M YOUR WORST NIGHTMARE."
Umm... Okay, alright.
That is... just probably not true.
"WHAT ARE YOU TALKING ABOUT?"
"I'M GONNA EAT YOUR SOUL RIGHT OUT YOUR ASS."
Uhh did you just threaten to eat my ass?
"NOO. THAT'S NOT AT ALL WHAT I THINK."
Uhhmm
Listen. I've... I... I don't consent to any of that so I'm just gonna...
I'm just gonna actually leave you there because you are creepy as hell.
And I'm not even gonna bother with you.
Blugh-huh.
Nightmare BB. What is Nightmare BB? OOOH.
THOSE ARE BALLOONS.
Oh boy.
Nightmare BB is gonna be a BIG BOI.
Oh we are gonna have a big balloon boy aren't we?
Balloon boy?
OOH SHIT. OOOH.
I'm not tiny though, that's good. *BB laughs*
Whuh?
Oboe?
Hello?
Oh how am I-?! How am I supposed to be able to do this? [BB laughs]
Heeey...
You're still there? You're still even on that. You bsdhfjh go away!
[BB laughs]
Okay, yeah, he's on the ground over there, I think.
Hoo!
Okay, he moved.
Okay. Alright. This is fine.
Hoo.
Did he move?
[BB laughs]
Now don't be thrown off by that.
Okay, he's real close right there. That's okay.
[BB vocalizes]
HUEY!
Hoo! He went away! I don't know where he went but he's there.
[BB laughs]
OH. OOH OOO-kay.
Alright. A little more. A little more.
[Jumpscare Warning]
[Mark+BB both scream]
URGGGG
*signs*
God damn it.
[Jumpscare Warning]
You fu-- OH MY GOD!!!
Alright.
That actually got me.
That got me real good.
Yeah it got me real good.
Okay, but not gonna... I think I punched my knuckle because my knuckle hurts.
Oh really?
Okay, I guess I'm going back in now, alright.
Where are you, you son of a bitch?
There you are.
Okay cool. Good.
YOU throw your balloon party.
Your stupid big bubbly balloon party.
You do whatever you want because I... I don't care.
You're gonna get your face full [BB laughs] of fist next time you come at me.
HUH? You come at me unprepared? You get un...
[BB laughs] your ass gonna be unprepared for this fist.
Ahh god dang it I gotta stop threatening people with a good time. [BB laughs]
Eh!
Okay...
[BB laughs]
Alright. Here we go.
EUEUH!!!
[BB laughs]
Oh shit.
YEEHHHY!
Huh OOH!
Okay, come on.
[BB laughs] Last chance, last chance.
Here we go. Here we go. Here we go.
Ehh DDDTTTT!
[Distressed] OH OOOHH OOHHH OHH great!
Great, great!
Great.
Ohhhh oooh HOOOOO HOOOOO! Hoooooo!
OOH!
[Normal] I GOT A 'LOON.
GUYS, I GOT A 'LOON.
Ooh I can't eat the 'loon?
No! My 'loon.
Oh shit.
Ahh tits.
DO YOU KNOW BOUT THIS?
YOU KNOW BOUT THIS ONE?
Hey. Come here. Can I touch you?
Ooh you're just outside the zone, OKAY ALRIGHT!
You be. Okay you be no touch but. I'mma get you.
Anyway do you know about this??? How dick this is?
Do you know?
Do you know how dit---Alright this is gonna SUCK.
I have no idea how they are gonna change it but it was bad before.
It was like impossible before how am I gonna do it now?
Alright whatever ok.
Alright.
I remember how to do the flashlights
Stupid
Ooh they're all– oh oh oh
[Distressed] WOW...HI..
Oh shit. Uh they're all...
If they're all like that then how... [Grunt]
Oh shit what the fu... Where is that?!
Baby: I guess you forgot about us
NO I DIDN'T FORGET I DON'T AHHHH COME ON
AHHAHAHHAHH!!! I dead
UUUAHHHHH
Oh shit
Hello?
Uh oh, well I'm doomed.
I'm doomed, ok.
There's gotta be... There's like one spazzing out somewhere?
Just shaking up a OOOOH...
[B laughs]
Yeah. Yeah I don't like it when you stare at me.
Kinda it gives a dead giveaway.
Ooh shit.
Dead giveaway!
[B laughs]
Deeaad giveaway.
♪ Dead Giveaway ♪
B: you should have known I'd find you
Oh my OOOOOHHHH
Wait x8
What?
Hello?
OOH.
I SAW THAT! I SAW ONE UP THERE!
B: two, one
Oh I'm fucked I'M FUCKED I'M FUCKED I'M FUCKED I'M FUCKED AHHHHHHH!!!!!
[B laughs]
I'm alive?
B: wanna see the scooping room?
NO I DON'T, no thank you.
ok, alright,
Okay, I'm doing ok. I'm doing ok.
♪ Somehow, I'm alive... ♪
♪ Don't know how, but I'm alive. ♪
♪ doesn't make a lot of sense ♪
B: I heard your call.
I see you...
I hear YOUR call.
I hear your call.
Come on,
Gimme x4
Just little flashes, little... little flooshes.
That's all I need.
ooooOOOOOHH
[B laughs]
Okay.
Little floshes. Little flickers
This is gonna be real hard on everybody's eyes
B:  You won't die,
Oh what
B: ...Two, one
You just moved... wait, you were... I'm gonna die
HUAHHHHHH!
This is fine
[Jumpscare Warning]
[Mark+Baby scream]
[Static]
URGGGGGGGGH
[Jumpscare Warning]
DRGRGRGRG
Ok back in.
EASY PEEZY, easy peez me.
Easy my peezes.
Okay, I think little flickers?
It's exactly... what we need
to beat this.
I see you up there.
Oh, they definitely are distinct
B: I heard your call
No no no, you didn't hear any call.
What call? OOOOOOOOO
I didn't call, I didn't call.
I did NOT call, I intentionally didn't call.
I would never call.
I'm not that type of... person.
Wait I saw... I saw, saw something over there.
Shit
There's got to be another one around here somewhere
B: You won't die
[B laughs]
I will.. not die, thank you for the reassurance,
[Grunt]
ok, alright
So there's only so many places that they could be
As long as I keep checking everywhere
OOOOOOO
[B laughs]
Ooh, I see you up there
You were hard to spot, admittedly
B: You should have know I'd find you
[B laughs]
Yeah I'd - well I mean I know a lot of things
but number one of them is that
I am going to LIIIIVE
[B laughs]
ok
There's a very behind the brain thing
Going on in my head
B: ...Two, one
no-no-noooo
No-no
[B laughs]
-no-no
no-no
[Jumpscare Warning]
[Mark+B both scream]
Wha... God freakin'– Goddamnit
Where were you?!?
Where were you?
[Jumpscare Warning]
Frickin' ger-gadurr
[Cupcake screams]
get you every time
Okay
Alright
So that's how it's going to be, huh?
[B laughs]
You go there
so
I'm just lookin'
casually
Shoom, shoom (x7)
Shoom,
wait- what
[Confused]
Wha-
[B laughs]
What's the whole disappearing act/thing
You can't just pop away, once I find you
Okay,
Shoom x11
[B laughs]
I feel like there's more
I think there's a problem, it's just flickering
Because it can make them move
[B laughs]
I see you
ok
good so far
so far so good
[B laughs]
is that one?
B: You won't die.
M: it was one
oh shit x2
oh fuck, oh shit
oh shit, I'm gonna die [Jumpscare Warning]
[Mark+B scream]
god damn it. they do the thing if I...
if I see them but I flicker away
frick, ok they're only [Jumpscare Warning]
BRAHHHH
[Cupcake screams]
they are only in so many zones
So long as I find the zones that they are in.
[B laughs]
and I check the zones
It's top
Center [thunk] and up
Is that one over there? No
Right? Yeah
[B laughs]
right there. Using a bit too much power
I can check these zones quicker
where are you?
B: ...Two, one
How? Oh, I see you
[B laughs]
ok, I'm looking for the eyes
it's real tricky
But I don't think it's that bad
come on
ok. I've missed one. I know I have
[B laughs]
I- my hindbrain is telling me that something is
oh, yea. right there
got you. oh, both of you.
[B laughs]
oh, two.
That's the other one
that's another hiding place that I've missed
back there. That was real hard
you're there.
[B laughs]
I see you.
oh two of you's
[B laughs x2]
ok, cool, good good good. so far so good
ok, what the hell
where are you?
[wooden creak]
oh shit, oh fuck ok that's- I'd ok
[B laughs]
ok
ok x4
B: You won't die
oh shit. There's another one. I hope I got em.
oh fuck. I'm gonna die...
I missed [Jumpscare Warning]
[Mark+B scream]
fuck x4. come on
[groan] shit
[Mark imitates Freddy laugh]
ho he, ho he, hoe he
[Jumpscare Warning]
[Cupcake screams]
frick... uh.., goddammit.
ok I was very close to the end
but I lost track of one of them.
and I could FEEL it in my head
it's weird that I can like
[B laughs]
FEEL it,
Like I now, I've seen something and it's not there
like something that out of place. It just a- it's a big where's waldo
where's wumbo
wittle wumbo
wumbo de tumbo
B: I guess you forgot about me.
M: Where the fuck are you?
[B laughs]
ok, a- up there
ok, a-up there
ok cool
that one was hard.You're there, ok, cool, easy
[B laughs]
easy x3. I got em
I got you guys
[B laughs]
ok, you can't hide from me.
doing so good
[B laughs]
doing sooo good
sooo good so far
B: you should have known I'd find you.
[B laughs]
oh, was that another one?
was there another one there?
up there. oof
oof oof, oofus oofus
ok, they are scooping up.
they're speeding their scoopers
where are you?
oh shit, oh fuck. there you are.
If I don't find one every few seconds
towards the end here
doll: do you want to see the scooping room?
no I don't. No that's right
ok I'm close, very close.
There you are
come on. Where are you? I know you're there. There you are
doll: two, one
no no, greuuuush. *sign*
ok, come one. You there, I see you
ok come on.
[victory bell toll] YES
It's not doing the thing
wait. is that a trick, are you tricking me.
you're tricking me aren't you. oh, I thought you were tricking me.
uurrgggghhhh
exotic beverage, woah
is that like exotic butters
300% carbs
[crunch sfx] that doesn't seem about right but ok I'll take it
yea, logical. I like logic, logic is good
oh,you're gone ok.
*sign* alright
*sign* ok, huff
Oh NO
this one was impossible as it was
oh not- oh shit
this one was impossible
How in the hell
HOW [Jumpscare Warning?]
ptf, what the fuck, what!?
what *laughs* excu- a fucking what?!
hi. [Jumpscare Warning]
what?
ok?
I'm sorry?
oh fuck me
oh eat my ass
oh, they all move
Oh My God
oh this is awful
I'm just gonna stand here and look at this and  die
but holy shit
oh my god
ha
I can't - I I can't. Just kill me.
Holy shit. You're over there
you're over there. There's multiple of you
ok,  but you don't seem to be moving that much
ok, ordinarily I'd be dead by now.
if it was the other thing, uh huh
uh huh, uh huh
what happens if I go here?
what was that? oh shit
oh you weren't even in play yet.
oh wait
oh, oh, your'e LOL
oh shit I'm- oh frick
ok yea I'm dead
just kill me, just kill me, kill me kill me kill me, just kill me
I hate this x6.
I hate this. I hate THAT
just fucking end me.
oh hi I hate.
oh god. I don't know where you went
oh fuck that. Fuck that in every way.
ok the- I'm too close to you
oh, too close still
ok. I'm not getting any farther
ok, I didn't see eyes
ok, there's eyes. I'm too close to that
who boy. Alright ok, come with me
who boy. Alright ok, come with me. This way x3
oh boy. Keep coming with me.
oh boy. come on
fuck
alright
ok
ok that's dangerous, that's real dangerous
ok, we're real close. uh oh
hooo too close. Too close, too close.
ok that's too close
way too close, way too close
way too close. Come on this way
this way this way.
*Mark whispers* all good
*incomprehensible whispers from Mark*
*Mark groans*
*Mark groan*
oohhhhhhhhh
*sigh* ok
hehehe, ha
oh wait, what. don't jumpscare me.
I- I don't like this- I can't grab it .
why can't I grab this, don't you want to be eaten by me, huh?
you wanna be eaten, you come on, I know you do. come on
where are you? come on just give me. Just give me a tantalizing taste of you
oh come oh I just want a sweet treat that can't be beat
oh come on please. Please with your buck teeth
and your oversaturated fats.
hummm, yum yum yum
I want the sugar, get in me. Cmon, give me some sugar. please, please, please.
oohhh
alright well.
it's a- it's apparently a ghost cupcake
it don't exist in this plane of reality
pfft. Ok fine then goodbye
I guess you won't be eaten today
stupid. ok so that is
oh fuck
pizza party, wait, why does that look like that?
wait a minute
why does that look like that
that- that's clearly the curtain there
wait, that one doesn't have- that one
wait thats that one
that one has stars on it. That  one doesn't have stars on it.
and remember one time- like in the first episode I did of this when the curtain came up
what was that all about, why did I see them? then!
that's alot of questions I don't know the answer too
but for now, we're gonna get out of nightmare world
and a- we are going to continue that in the next one.
so we've only got one thing left
and it's probably gonna be the ultimate challenge  in this game
but I've been pretty good at all of these challenges thus far
so thank you, everybody, so much for watching
there is probably only going to be one more episode of this game
but might I say this has been
a really cool experience, this has been one of the best five nights at freddy's it's oh-
it's it's - it's probably one of my favourite five nights at freddy's games ever made.
just because it's so immersive, it's so terrifying
it really brings the fear to life.
it's just awesome, I love this alot
so thank you, everybody, so much for watching,
a check out all the other Five Nights at Freddy's stuff I've done in the description below or in the recommended videos
subscribe fro more cool stuff, ring that bell, hit that like
thanks guys so much for being here and as always, I'll see you in the next video. Buh Bye
outro plays haunted by shurk